how many people have viewed like this
video of habib at the age of nine
wrestling this bear and how many people
have talked about that and you know it's
almost like men they respect his
dedication to his craft they respect his
father's dedication to the craft so it's
like you already have my respect and in
that moment to say to someone look if
you really respect me if you really want
to know what has formed the man that you
see before you and you admire the man
that you see before you
it's not the bear wrestling it's not
even the training it's vlad ilaha
illallah Muhammad auto solo mom yes it's
the fact that there is no god but God or
there's nothing worthy of worship
besides God and that Muhammad is the
Messenger of God that what had that is
what is really responsible for the men
that you see before you
it's powerful and profound down that's
what's giving Habib the edge of course
and that's how his cub opponents could
get to any anyone can get the edge
absolutely by doing this of course you
know there's nothing more powerful than
faith I don't care what anybody says
there's nothing more powerful than faith
nothing even to someone that's an
unbeliever
if you encounter somebody that believes
in something very deeply you're affected
by the fact that what they believe in it
it's like man I don't believe in it but
if I have to go against someone who
believes in what they're doing I mean
because belief cannot be extinguished it
cannot be like that and to me that is
what that was really the difference when
you think about kind of saying it's just
business know what that kind of I don't
know kind of McGregor's beliefs and he's
from Ireland so I'd assume he was
Catholic and although there's Irish and
Catholics and Irish Protestant but what
was more clear about Kirby was that may
he believes and something I believe that
if I'm in a fight there's something I'm
fighting for that's more important than
just business yeah even though Connors
saying look I'm really just fighting for
the money and there was one point where
Connor was even saying that he's God
next to God that he'll even beat up God
he was actually saying he was saying
this it's crazy I think any man god man
I mean not only that what God I was
what so you hear some crazy stuff like
Ref you just saw yeah so this when you
hear this stuff you're like come on this
guy's out of his mind now and is this a
good time where you can take your kids
you can take the rowdy ones who have
gotten a little bit on the borderline of
arrogant and maybe they're into the
sport you say hold on you like Habib why
don't you do what he's doing on the
other aspect don't follow it where he
said this is not the best of me but the
best of his of him is when he takes his
head and puts it on the ground when he
says himself stay connected to God
doesn't matter what type of you looks
like you always have to pray you always
have to stay humble and stay focused and
stay connected to God Lisa's very
important loss and me keep it humble
when people are going more towards the
lines of me me III and that arrogance
and this is what God hates mm-hmm is
this a good tool now that people can
watch man you know you know there's a
thought that I you know toy around with
now you know people say there's a thin
line between love and hate
there's actually a thin line between
boasting and gratitude because the
bolster is magnifying the blessing
whatever it is they have their
magnifying that you know whether it's
their ability or but they never
attribute that blessing to the one that
gave it to them the only difference a
person that is the only difference in a
person that is grateful is not only am i
magnifying the blessing i'm magnifying
the one who gave me the blessing so if
you have any ability and it's bigger
than khabib it's big if you have any
ability if you have you know an ability
to speak and ability to write an ability
to help people find cures when they're
sick if you have an ability to do
anything you have to recognize all of
these are not in these are blessings
from God and if you want to show your
gratitude to God for giving you those
blessings you know it's interesting the
Arabic language is a beautiful language
the word for talent is mo Hiba because
it comes from the WA ha
the bus tour God is the bus tour of
talents and if you want to show
gratitude for what you have been given
it is not for you to beat your chest and
say look at me is to put your head on
the floor and say thank you for giving
me the ability that you've given me
that's what it's about so if I had a
young person that was really excited
about could be been his ability as a
martial artist and as a grappler and as
a wrestler I was a much more important
than his ability is that he recognizes
who gave him the ability and if you want
to be like him recognize who will give
you your ability if you want to you know
develop the skill and recognize who gave
you the ability that you have that's
much more important don't be a person
that just you know achee you know
esteems the talent or the skill or the
ability or you know God gave this to you
similarly we shouldn't be people who
don't appreciate what God has given some
people think that like humbleness is
being self-deprecating oh I'm nothing
I'm that are nothing I'm nobody
you know God didn't make you nothing God
didn't make you nobody he gave you these
abilities for Emma beam a meteo beaker
for hadith as for the blessing of your
Lord proclaim it but make sure you
proclaim it as what the blessing of your
Lord don't proclaim it as my ability
proclaiming is what the blessing of my
lord
look at what my Lord has given to me and
it's not enough just to say it you have
to show your gratitude by doing what he
told you to do if I say to my father
when they let him enter than Allah
of course it's hard to make any parable
about God you know Dan I appreciate
everything that you've given me and I
appreciate what you've done for me and I
appreciate the sacrifice that you've
made for me and my father asked me okay
so I need you to be home at 9:00 and you
know break the leaves and take out the
trash and I'm not doing any of that I'm
not coming home at 9:00 I'm not raking
leaves I'm not taking out trash but I
really appreciate everything that you've
done for me I really appreciate the
great sacrifice that you've made for me
then it's just lip service the service
yeah it's nothing to show that
appreciation to show that gratitude is
do what that told you to do action now
is action it's action time now it's go
time